you can't find your passion because
you're currently believing certain lies
that you've been told
make it almost impossible to figure it
out i finally felt mine but i could have
saved years of my life if i understood
what i'm going to share with you here so
you can figure out yours potentially
quicker than me to make a long story
short i tried multiple things
did some deep introspection listened to
all the advice and found what has been
holding me back all this time
so sit back relax and enjoy the video
also take notes that could help i found
myself at a point where i had a thriving
business
selling my own physical products online
basically making money on autopilot
living the dream that everybody talked
about
but i hated every single day of it i was
selling products i didn't care about to
people i
didn't know and i had to force myself to
get things done to grow it and as an
ambitious weirdo just like you i knew
that in order to live a truly fulfilling
life which is what this channel is all
about
i knew i had to fix this because i was
just wasting my valuable lifetime
so i decided to sell the business cashed
out big and even though i could have
just not worked for the next few years
if i wanted to
i couldn't sit still i wanted to start
the business that i knew i would love
my idea was to build a business that
would bring like-minded ambitious
action-driven people together because i
was so lonely at the time and i hated it
and i wanted to solve that problem so i
started running meetups started a
podcast interviewing people
running business retreats with young
entrepreneurs and i was really excited
about it
until i wasn't something was off
i ended up not liking any of it and it
still
felt like work just like it did before
and this is the first thing that i got
wrong that holds people back from
finding their passion i think a lot of
people
glorified as a superpower where they
think if they're really passionate they
just get up super excited every morning
they levitate through the room
and when they get to their laptop the
work just flows through their fingers
and they never procrastinate they never
deal with resistance and everything is
just so easy for them because after all
if you really loved it you wouldn't need
discipline right
wrong so you may love writing but you
find yourself procrastinating on it and
then you think oh
it looks like it's not my passion then
not knowing that even the best writers
in the world
procrastinate and feel resistance every
single day
and no matter what you're going after
there's always going to be this huge
chunk of tasks
and activities and things that are
involved that you're going to hate
think about it this way you might like
surfing but you're always going to have
to paddle out first against the wave to
get out there in the first place so you
can actually catch a wave and get to the
fun part
by the way have you noticed how good my
analogies are like so
deep like man if you gotta be a surfer
you gotta
go against so building that business
didn't come to fruition because
yeah i apparently i don't like it and i
thought what else can i do
maybe i could do consulting because that
way i could get in touch with
like-minded entrepreneurs i would just
work with established entrepreneurs and
help them actually prepare their
business for sale
just like i did with my business but
still i hated it
at that point i became pretty hopeless a
year had gone by
and in my mind it seemed like it was
completely wasted i made no progress
i started thinking am i maybe just not a
passionate guy
maybe i don't have a passion so moving
forward i
had an identity crisis and this is a
crucial step
i believe for finding your passion
probably for you as well so make sure
you keep an open mind and you listen
carefully because
this could really change things for you
i slowly started
to just question everything that i
believed about myself
so until this point i was the business
guy i looked up to entrepreneurs
i was an entrepreneur i'd already built
and sold the business but i started
thinking
what if i'm actually not an entrepreneur
that was a really
scary thought for me because in my mind
you can only be really successful if you
are
entrepreneurial but i started to just
dig into these possibilities
and that's when i committed to
developing real
self-awareness and figuring out who i
actually am i would say the best tool
for you
will be journaling and actually sitting
down and asking yourself really deep
questions that only you can answer
because the answers are inside of you
things like
what have i always been naturally drawn
to as a child what comes
easy to me that doesn't come easy to
everyone if there's only one task i
could do for the rest of my life
what would it be to get to know myself
more i then took
multiple personality tests i'd already
taken the myers-briggs personality test
and it described me as the person that
all my friends knew me as
you know really systematic intense
structured
disciplined just very strict but at that
point i became
curious and i retook the test what
showed up this time
was completely different i was an enfj
the protagonist it was like a paper of a
scientist
that had perfectly analyzed me like
i was an animal on national geographic
that was also
pretty cool analogy right you gotta give
that to me and then i took the disc
personality test which
describes four different types also as
animals which are dolphins
whales owls and sharks the sharks were
the ones that were really
intense and ambitious and driven and i
knew hey i'm definitely a shock
and guess what i ended up being
a dolphin and i couldn't lie to myself
this
was very accurate but i didn't want it
to be
what if you can't find your passion
because
you're not really being you you don't
embrace who you actually
are you're wishing you were someone else
that you are not
i wanted to be an entrepreneur i wanted
to be one of them
but that was not my main driver in life
it's something that i
had learned as a behavior so i thought
does that mean i
can't have a business that i'll never be
passionate about it that i should maybe
just
get a job i'm gonna explain it later but
first of all i want to
call you out on something i want to
challenge you that you
already know what you are passionate
about
you sneaky little weasel while i'm
telling you this you're like
i don't know what i'm really passionate
about and it's actually blindingly
obvious
you already know your passions you're
just not being true
to yourself or you have forgotten who
you actually are at your core and maybe
you're thinking
no i really don't but stick with me here
let's actually explore this a bit deeper
when i started to question my
entrepreneur identity that i built up
over the years
i took the advice to actually ask
friends and family
what they think your passion might be
asking them what do you think i'm good
at
what do you come to me for advice for
specifically for your family what was it
like
growing up with me or seeing me grow up
what was i naturally drawn to
that way you could find out who you were
as a child
before you beca started becoming someone
else that's what i was trying to say and
i remember my sister
telling me that i don't know you're
really
entertaining you're good at making
people laugh
and i remember being like how is that
going to help me what am i gonna be the
chief entertainment officer at a company
that was actually a crucial bit of
information that at the time i just
brushed off
and the reason why you are not embracing
that
is because you believe that your passion
needs to be something productive
something legitimate something real when
in reality
it's right there in front of you you are
just
avoiding it for whatever reason you're
avoiding it you're telling yourself oh
well i love comic books but that doesn't
count
you can't make money with comic books
see there was a time where you
didn't have requirements attached to
what you liked and
this has to lead into something this has
to be something and you might think well
when i was a child i liked video games
and hanging out with my friends
so where does that go let me explain it
to you because the next misconception is
that you think that
passions are something that is very
tangible very obvious and specific
for example you like painting you like
design you like
building a business or just a topic like
cars or sports
but this is such a surface level view
when reality a passion is not something
you can quite
put your finger on it's very complex and
very beneath the surface and very deep
while you might think you like superhero
comic books
when you really dig in you find that
what you actually like is the empowering
storytelling that allows people to see a
strength in themselves that they didn't
see before
you don't like eating at restaurants you
like the attention to detail
that makes the simple things in life
extraordinary you don't like
documentaries
you like communicating ideas that expand
people's minds
it's your job to figure out through
self-awareness and journaling and asking
yourself the right questions
what it is about your existing passions
that you
actually like what is beneath the
surface so if you like video games as a
kid
what was it about that was it the
storytelling was it the competitiveness
what
was it the community what is it and from
there you see these
endless possibilities that show up in
different careers and companies that you
could build
that might not even have anything to do
with video games because video games is
just a vehicle
for the underneath passion that's
actually beneath that and i thought hey
maybe i don't like business
the reality is there's infinite ways to
approach business in a way where you can
make it fun
see i think there are three components
to a passion one of the components
is the purpose component which is what i
just discussed for example you like
expanding people's minds the second
component of a passion is the topic so
it's just maybe golf
social media marketing fiction books
might be something that you're just
naturally drawn to or just maybe
something you have a little bit of an
interest in so for me
i couldn't be passionate about
horses sorry horses i'm
not interested in you guys see i wasn't
passionate about my e-commerce business
because i was selling
baby products but if i were to sell
products related to personal growth
completely different story there's
infinite ways to approach
business depending on the topic
depending on the purpose and then
the third component of a passion is the
activities these are just things that
you
do day to day that are your main thing
see i had a buddy who liked marketing
and he was starting up his business
and he just admired how in my podcast
that i dabbled in when i was trying to
find my passion how i was just so
comfortable in front of the camera and
he was like how does that come so easily
to you and he was in complete
disbelief thinking like what's wrong
with me and it turns out that he
actually believed that something that he
had to do because it's just like you
know content you gotta make content
everyone has to make content all the
time and what he told me he liked
instead
was building marketing funnels which is
where you use this software and you have
to like drag and drop and have to like
do these little design thingies and just
and i was like
dude you really enjoy doing that that's
the most draining and horrible thing
that i can think of
so what you enjoy others might hate and
that could be a thing
so when it comes to figuring out the
activity part of your passion the core
thing to look at is energy what
activities
drain your energy and what activities
give you energy
and after a while you have some really
good self-awareness of who you actually
are
by the way i'm looking for more people
to be featured in my content just like
dan when i helped him deal with his
phone addiction so if you need help with
building a business or finding your
passion or whatever it is that you need
help with there will be a link below
back to the video so everything starts
with self-awareness with really getting
to know yourself because
write that down there's gonna be some
really smart thing here your level of
self-awareness is in direct
proportion to your level of satisfaction
in life in any area
whether it's relationships your work uh
how you feel about yourself the more you
know yourself
the better your life gets but from there
once you know more about yourself
how does that actually translate into a
business that you want to start or
a career that you want to pursue the
first thing you should do is really just
explore if you feel like doing something
just
follow it and do it for the sake of it
without thinking about where it might
lead or if it's just a waste of time as
an example i
started just making a sketch about
entrepreneurship and just
make people laugh it was the first time
that something came
pretty easily to me and even though it
sucked people really liked it and my
friends from australia who knew me as
this really
systematic intense discipline guy were
actually really surprised to see that
side of me which i'd never seen before
and that's when i knew
i had rediscovered who i really was i
was
someone that liked being silly like
being you know a clown sometimes
my sister was right all along and i saw
how all these dots from the past
connected
you can't really look too far ahead it's
kind of like this fog where you want to
figure out what's ahead but you only
know the next step as you are taking a
step forward which again really is a
amazing analogy of mine that i just made
up
so you want to experiment with an open
mind and then keep adjusting based on
how you feel and just try different
things
before i give you the most important
thing let's just make this long story
short
i kept making these sketches then i
started a new channel where i was making
these adventure videos and then
transitioning to where i am now with
this content
i want to build the tightest community
for those who don't fit in because we're
too ambitious and
we are actually crazy enough to go after
what we truly want in life to live
without regrets and the most important
thing for you to keep in mind is just to
keep experimenting and your goal is to
narrow
it down where you try different things
and you get closer and closer
to your ideal situation as you keep
adjusting what often holds people back
from here is just procrastination which
is why i made this video over here where
i discuss literally
a quick fix i know it sounds flashy but
it really is just
go and check it out click here and i'll
see you over there